29 juillet c'est le jour du dépassement
mondiale chaque année la larme sonne un
peu plus tôt à partir d'aujourd'hui
l'humanité a épuisé ce que la terre peut
lui fournir qu'elle se soit de l'ordre
de l'agriculture les pêches la
foresterie les énergies les énergies
fossiles que l'on utilisé qu'on continue
à exploiter
eh ben on vit à crédit pas surprenant
c'est très inquiétant
équiterre soutient pleinement cette
initiative considérée comme alarmiste
mais nécessaire c'est vrai que c'est un
outil parmi d'autres pour pour
conscientiser la population pour alarmer
la population pour effectuer des
comparaisons certes mais qui doivent
nécessairement mener à l'action en
particulier ici au canada
car selon le global footprint network
qui publie cet indicateur
si le monde entier vivait comme les
canadiens la planète arriverait au bout
de ses ressources le 18 mars
parmi les pays qui font pire les
etats-unis mais aussi le qatar les
émirats arabes unis ou le koweït le 14
c'est pour dire nous surconsommons nous
gaspillons nos ressources
pourtant si à bordeaux si précieuse en
observant cette carte on constate que le
canada à l'une des meilleures
biocapacité au monde
mais si l'on regarde l'empreinte
écologique par personne le tableau est
bien moins réjouissant tout le monde ne
cède pas à la panique pour autant
c'est quelque chose qui ne m'empêche pas
de dormir car l'humanité serait
suffisamment résiliente que rebondir
départ soit passé à sienne mais je pense
que le passé nous a démontré que l'oeil
humain était avait une capacité
d'innovation qui faisait qu'on passait
outre ces problèmes de finition
je trouve que c'est un peu provocateur
parce qu'un fait on est loin de manquer
de ressources sa sont sur la planète
si on manquait de ressources les prix
des ressources de base en général
seraient à la rousse et ce n'est pas le
cas et des initiatives comme le nouveau
guide alimentaire canadien qui vise à
diminuer la consommation de viande vont
dans le bon sens selon les experts en
environnement
si mathieu prost radio canada montréal